The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last time
we defined the expected
value of a random variable.
And we talked about a lot of
ways it could be computed.
We proved all sorts of
equivalent definitions.
Today, we're going to keep
talking about expectation.
And we're going to start
with an example that
talks about the expected
number of events
that you expect to have occur.
And it's a
generalization of what
we did with Chinese appetizer
and hat check from last time.
We're going to call
this theorem 1.
If you have a
probability space, s,
and you've got a
collection of n events,
let's call them A1 through
A n, and these are just
subsets of s, then the expected
number of events to occur,
of these events, is simply
the sum of i equals 1 to n
of the probability of
the i-th event occurring.
So you just sum up
the probabilities
that the events occur.
And that tells you
the expected number
of events that will occur.
So a very simple formula.
So for example, A i
might be the event
if the i-th man gets the
right hat back from last time.
Or it could be the event
if the i-th person gets
the right appetizer back
at the Chinese restaurant
after we spin the
wheel in the center.
So we're going to prove this.
And the proof is very similar
to what we did last time when
we figured out the
expected number of people
to get the right hat back.
In particular, we're going
to start by setting up
an indicator variable, T sub
i, that tells us whether or not
the i-th event, A sub i occurs.
So we define T sub i-- and it's
a function of a sample point--
to be 1 if the sample
point is in the i-th event,
meaning the i-th event
occurs, and 0 otherwise.
And this is just
another way of saying
that T sub i is 1 if and only
if A sub i happens or occurs.
Now what we care about is the
number of events that occur.
And we get that just by
summing up the T sub i.
So we'll let T be
T1 plus T2 plus T n.
And that'll count because
we'll get a 1 every time
an event occurs.
By adding those up,
we'll get the number
of events that occur.
All right.
Now we care about
the expected value
of T, the expected number
of events to occur.
And I claim that's just
the sum i equals 1 to n
of the expected value of T i.
Why is that true?
Why is the expected value of T
the sum of the expected values
of the T sub i?
Linearity of expectations.
Now did we need the T sub i's to
be independent events for that?
No.
OK, very good.
Now the expected value of T
i is really easy to evaluate.
It's just a 0, 1 variable.
So it's just the
probability that T i is 1
because it's 1 times this plus
0 times the probability of 0,
and that cancels out.
And the event that
T i equals 1 is just
the situation where the i-th
event occurs because T i equals
1 is the case that A i occurs.
That's what it is.
So we've shown that the expected
number of events to occur
is simply the sum
of the probabilities
that the events occur.
So a very simple
formula, very handy.
And you don't need
independence for that.
Any questions about that?
We're going to use that
theorem a lot today.
As a simple example, suppose
we flip n fair coins.
And we let A i be the event
that the i-th coin is heads.
And suppose we want to know
the expected number of heads
in the n flips.
Well, we can use this theorem.
The expected number
of heads is just
going to be the sum
of the probabilities
that each coin is a heads.
So let's do that.
T is the number of heads.
We want to know the
expected value of T.
And from theorem
one, that's just
the probability the first coin
is heads plus the probability
the second coin is heads.
And the same out to the
probability the n-th coin
is heads.
What's the probability
the first coin is heads?
And 1/2.
The probability the second
coin is heads is a 1/2.
The probability the last
coin is heads is 1/2.
And so the expected number of
heads-- we add up 1/2 n times--
is just n/2.
Of course, you all knew that.
If you flip n fair coins,
the expected number of heads
is half of them.
But that's a very
simple way to prove it.
Did we need the coin
tosses to be mutually
independent to conclude that?
No.
I could've glued them
together in some weird way.
In fact, I could have glued
some face up and some face down
and done weird
things, and you still
expect n/2 heads even if
they were glued together
in strange ways.
Because I don't
need independence
for linearity of
expectation to prove this.
Now that's the easy
way to evaluate
the expected number of heads.
There is a hard way to do it.
Let me set that up.
We could start from
the definition,
a different definition, namely,
that the expected value of T
is the sum from i equals 0 to n.
i times the probability
that you have i heads.
This would be a
natural way to compute
the expected number of heads.
You add up the
case where there's
zero heads times the
probability of 0,
1 times the probability
of one head, 2 times
probably two heads,
and so forth.
That's one of the first
definitions of expectation.
So let's keep trying to do this.
What is the probability
of getting i heads?
And now I'm going
to have to assume
mutual independence actually.
Now I'm going to need
mutual independence.
So already, this
method isn't as good
because I had to
make that assumption
to answer this question.
If you don't make
that assumption,
you can't answer that question.
What's the probability of
getting i heads out of n.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: s to the n-th
power times n [INAUDIBLE] i.
PROFESSOR: Yes, because if
you look at the sample space,
there are 2 to the n sample
points all equally likely.
They're all probability
2 the minus n.
And there's n choose i of
them that have i heads.
And now you'd have to
evaluate that sum which
is sort of a pain.
That one won't come
to mind readily.
So you might say I reached
sort of a dead end here.
But in fact, the answer
is easy to use, easy
to get using this method.
In fact, we've actually
proved an identity here
because we know
the answer is n/2.
We've just proved that
this messy thing is n/2.
In fact, you can multiply
by 2 to the n here.
We have proved, using
probability theory and theorem
1 over there, the sum of
i n choose i equals n 2
to the n minus 1.
Just multiply by 2 to
the n on each side.
So we've given a
probability based
proof of this identity which is
sort of hard to do otherwise,
could be harder to do.
Any questions about that?
So again, if it comes time for
a homework problem or a test
problem, if it
naturally divides up
in this way where you can
take a random variable when
you got a computer's expectation
to make it a sum of indicator
variables, if that is a natural
thing to do, do it that way.
Because it's so much
easier than trying
to go from the
definition because you
might encounter
nasty things like
that that you got to evaluate.
So in this case,
we flipped n coins.
We expect n/2 heads.
In the hat check, in
Chinese appetizer problems--
we had n hats or n
appetizers-- we expected
to get one back to the right
person-- so a smaller expected
value.
For some problems, the
expected value is even less.
The expected number of events
to occur is less than 1.
In fact, it might
be much less than 1.
Now in those cases it turns
out that the expected value
is an upper bound
on the probability
that one or more events occur.
We're going to state
this as theorem 2.
The probability that at
least one event occurs
is always upper bounded by
the expected number of events
to occur.
Now this theorem
is pretty useless
if the expected number of
events to occur is bigger than 1
because all probabilities
are at most 1.
But if the expected
number of events to occur
is small, something
much less than 1,
this is a pretty useful bound.
So let's prove that.
The expected value of
T-- and in this case
we'll use one of the definitions
we have of expected value,
name of the one
where you sum from i
equals 1 to infinity
of the probability T
is greater than or equal to i.
Now what did we have to know
about T to use that definition?
That doesn't work for
all random variables
T. What condition do I have on
T to be able to use this one?
Anybody remember?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Must be defined
on the natural numbers?
PROFESSOR: T must defined
on the natural numbers.
If it is, I can use this
very simple definition.
And is T defined on the
natural numbers here?
Is the range of T
natural numbers?
Well, I'm counting the number
of events that occurred.
Could be 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Has to be a natural number.
So it's OK.
So I can use this definition.
Now this is summing up
probability T is at least 1
plus probability T is
at least 2 and so forth.
I'm just going to
use the first term.
This is at least the
size of the first term
because probabilities
are non-negative.
So I'm just going to throw away
all the terms after the first
and conclude that this is
at least the probability T
is bigger than or equal to 1.
And I'm done.
I just look at it in reverse.
The probability of at
least one event occurring
is at most the expected value.
Very simple.
There's a very quick
corollary here.
The probability
at least one event
occurs is at most the sum of
the probabilities of the events.
And the proof there is
just plugging in theorem 1.
Because the expected value is
the sum of the probabilities.
So we just plug-in theorem
1 for the expected value
because it's just that.
Any questions about the proof?
Very simple.
Now this theorem is very
useful in situations
where you're trying
to upper bound
the probability of some kind
of disaster or something
bad happening.
For example, suppose
you want to compute
the probability that a
nuclear plant melts down.
Now actually, the
government does this.
They got to figure
this thing out
because if it's a high
probability, well,
we're not going to allow
anybody to build them.
And the way they do it is they
convene a panel of experts.
They get some people from
various good universities
and they bring them
down to Washington.
And they have them
figure out every way
they can think of that
a meltdown could occur,
every possible event that
would lead to a meltdown.
And then they'd have them
figure out the probability
for each one of those events.
For example, A1
could be the event
that the operator goes
crazy and makes it meltdown.
A2 could be the event that an
earthquake hits and the cooling
pipes are ruptured, and
then you got a meltdown.
A3 is the event that terrorists
shoot their way in and cause
a meltdown.
So you've got a lot of
possibilities for how
the thing can melt down.
And then they compute
the probabilities.
And then they add them up
just using this result.
And they say, well,
the probability
that a meltdown-causing
event or one or more occurs
is at most this small number.
And hopefully it's small.
So for example, suppose there's
100 ways that a meltdown could
occur, 100 things that
could cause a meltdown.
And each one happens with
probability one in a million.
What can you say
about the probability
that a meltdown occurs?
You got a hundred ways
it could happen only.
Each is a one in
a million chance.
What's the probability
a meltdown occurs?
1 in 10,000 because you're
adding up one in a million
100 times.
n is 100.
Each of these is
one in a million.
So you get 100 over a million.
There's 1 in 10,000.
And so then they
publish a report that
says the chance of this reactor
melting down is 1 in 10,000.
Now what if I've
got 100 reactors?
What's the chance that at
least one of them melts down?
1 in 100 because I got 100
over 10,000-- same theorem.
So there's a 1 in 100 chance
something melts down somewhere,
at most.
Hopefully, the numbers
are better than that.
Same thing if you bought
100 lottery tickets, each
a one in a million
chance, you got a 1
in 10,000 chance of
winning, at most.
So simple fact but powerful
and used a lot in practice.
And this is sort of
the good case when
the expected number of
events that are bad to happen
is small, like a
lot less than 1.
But what if the expected number
of events to happen is big.
Say it's 10.
Say this government
panel gets together
and they add up all
the probabilities
and it comes out to be 10.
Well, it doesn't sound so
good if that's the case.
But is it necessarily bad?
Does it necessarily
mean that you're
going to have a meltdown.
So for example,
let's say there's
1,000 ways you could melt down.
And let's say that the
probability of each one
is 1 in 100.
So the expected number of
things that could happen
to cause a meltdown is 10.
Am I guaranteed we're
going to melt down?
No.
Can anybody think
of a way where it's
unlikely we're
going to melt down
but respect these values
here, hypothetically?
Is there any chance
that it's still
unlikely to have a meltdown?
We're going to think of a way?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They all
happen at the same time.
PROFESSOR: They all
Now the examples I gave you--
the terrorists, the earthquake,
and the crazy operator--
put that on the side.
If they all happen together,
when any one happens,
the others have to happen.
So we can express
that as for all ij,
probability of the
i-th event happening
given the j-th event happening
is one, so total dependence.
What's the probability of a
meltdown in that scenario?
What's the probability one of
those meltdown-inducing events
occurs?
They all happen at once.
AUDIENCE: 1 in 100.
PROFESSOR: 1 in 100.
Because it's the same as the
probability of the first event
happening which, by
definition, was 1 in 100.
So it could be that the
probability of a meltdown
is small.
But it might not be as well.
There's no way,
given this, to know.
What if I chain-- in fact,
this is like Chinese appetizer,
right?
If one person gets their
appetizer back, everybody does.
So there are circumstances
where you have
the total dependence like that.
Let's say I change a little bit
and I don't do this scenario.
In fact, say I
tell you the events
are mutually independent,
but you expect 10 to occur.
Do you sleep at night now?
Of course, 1% is still
a pretty high number.
But how many people think that
if they're mutually independent
and you expect 10
that, no matter what,
there's a least a 50%
chance of a meltdown?
Anybody?
OK.
In fact, if you expect 10 and
they're mutually independent,
a meltdown is a
virtual certainty.
The chance you don't melt
down is less than 1 in 22,000.
For sure something
will occur that's bad.
And this is a theorem
that we call Murphy's law.
And Murphy's law, probably
you've all heard of it,
it says-- it's a famous saying.
If something can go
wrong, it will go wrong.
And we're going to see
why that's true, at least,
in our circumstances here.
That's a pretty
powerful theorem.
If you have mutually independent
events A1 through A n, then
the probability that none
of them occur, t equals 0,
is upper bounded by e to the
minus expected number of events
to occur.
So if I expect 10 to occur,
the chance that none do
is upper bounded by e to the
minus 10, which is very small,
which means almost surely one of
the events or more will occur.
And that's bad
news in this case.
So let's prove that.
Well, the probability
that t equals 0
is the same as the probability
that A1 does not occur
and A2 does not occur and all
the way to A n does not occur.
And I claim this
[INAUDIBLE] is the product
of the probabilities
they don't occur.
So I'm taking the
product i equals 1 to n
of the probability that
A i does not occur.
Now why can I make that step?
Yeah.
Independence.
This is the product rule
for independent events.
Now the probability
that A i does not occur
is simply 1 minus the
probability it does occur.
And now I'm going to
use a simple fact, which
is that for any
number x, 1 minus x
is at most e to the minus x.
Just a simple fact from algebra.
So I've got 1 minus-- I'm
going to treat this as the x.
So this is at most e to the
minus probability of A i
using that fact.
And now I'll take the
product and put it
into a sum in the exponent.
And then some of the
probabilities of the events
is just the expected value.
That was theorem 1
that I just erased.
So this is e to the minus
expected number of events
to occur.
So not too hard a proof.
We had to use that fact.
But that gets the
expected number of events
to occur in the exponent.
So a simple corollary
is the case when
we expect 10 events to occur.
So if we expect 10 or more
mutually independent events
to occur, the probability
that no event occurs
is at most e to the minus
10, which is less than 1
over 22,000.
Now there's not even any
dependence on n here.
It had nothing to do with a
number of possible events,
just that if you expect
10 of them to occur,
you're pretty sure
one of them will.
And this explains why you
see weird coincidences.
Or people sometimes see what
they think are miracles.
Because out in the
real world, there's
billions of possible weird
things that could happen.
You just can create all
sorts of crazy possibilities.
And each one might be
one in a billion chance
of actually happening.
But you got billions
that could've.
And if they're all
mutually independent--
because you made up all these
different things-- than you
expect some of them to happen.
And so you should--
in fact, you're
going to know that for sure
some of those weird things
are going to happen.
At least the chance that
no weird thing happens
is 1 in 22,000.
And so this can be why
somebody will go along
and say, oh my goodness.
You won't believe what
happened, a coincidence.
And it's like, wow, the
chance of that happening
was one in a billion.
It must've been a miracle or an
act of God that this happened.
But you're not thinking about
the other 10 billion things
that didn't happen.
So for sure some of those
things are going to happen.
It's not likely that I'm going
to win megabucks next week.
But somebody's going to win.
If enough people play
and it's more than 1
over the probability
that you're going to win,
than it's very
likely somebody will
win if everybody is
guessing randomly.
Any questions about
what we're doing?
So this is amazingly powerful,
this result. In fact,
it's so powerful that
it's going to let me read
somebody's mind in the class.
We're going to do a
little card trick here.
Now the way this
card trick works--
it's a little complicated.
I'm going to need a
volunteer, probably one of you
guys down front.
We'll get you.
And one of your buddies is going
to keep you honest for me here.
I'm going to reveal--
first I'm going
to let you shuffle the deck.
So go ahead and shuffle
it, do whatever you want.
It's a normal deck.
It's got 52 cards
and two jokers.
And I don't care what
order they're in.
I'm going to turn over
the cards one at a time.
Now I'm going to ask you to
pick a number from 1 to 9
ahead of time.
Don't tell me or anybody else.
In fact, I'm going to want
you guys to play along too.
And we're going to see
where we all end up here.
And that's your starting number.
And as I turn over the
cards one at a time--
say you started with a 3 was
the number you had in mind--
on the third card I show,
that becomes your card.
You don't tell me or jump
up and down or anything.
But that's your card.
And say it's a 4 of diamonds.
Now a 4 replaces the
three in your mind
and you count 4 more cards,
then that becomes your card.
Now let's say that's a jack or
a face card or a 10 or a joker.
10, face card, and
jokers all count as 1
just like an ace counts as 1.
And so then the next
card would be your card
because you count 1.
And we keep on going until you
have a card, maybe it's a 7.
But there's only four
cards left in the deck.
And so you don't get a new one.
And your last card is the 7.
And then you're going to write
that down here, not showing me.
And you're going to
do this, maybe do this
with a friend over there.
And you're going to make sure
you count right on the deck
because if you screw
up the counting,
it's going to be hard
for me to read your mind.
So just to make sure we
all understand this, let
me write the rules down here
because I want the whole class
to pick a number from 1 to
9 and play the same game.
And we're going to
see what happens.
So let me show you
the rules again just
to make sure
everybody understands.
So say the deck
starts out like this.
I got a 4, a 5.
So my first few cards of
the deck go like this.
10 equals a 1.
Then I got a queen equals a 1.
3, 7, 6, 4, 2.
Say it's a small deck.
I'm going to use 54 cards.
And say you're chosen number to
start, you start with a three.
As I show the cards, you're
going to count 1, 2, 3.
That becomes your new card.
Then you're going to count 1, 2.
That becomes your card.
It's a 10, so you
convert it to a 1
because we're only doing
single digit numbers.
Go to 1, that becomes your card.
Queen converts to a 1.
You go 1, that
becomes your card.
3, 1, 2, 3.
That becomes your card.
And you can't get 4, so you
remember the final card.
Does everybody understand
what you're supposed to do?
Because we're going to
do 54 cards of this.
Maybe we get the TAs
to play along here.
And as you do it, maybe you
want to talk to your buddy,
make sure you got
it worked out there.
And if I could read
your mind maybe
we'll have a gift
certificate or something.
So you shuffle the deck?
Got it good?
All right.
So I'm going to start revealing
the cards one at a time.
So you guys play along
quietly in your mind.
And we'll see if we can
concentrate long enough.
Aces are 1.
Jacks are 1.
10's are 1.
We're halfway done.
Jokers are 1.
OK.
That's the last card.
So remember the last
one that was yours.
And you got to go
check with your buddy
to make sure you guys agree
on the counting there.
And then write it down.
Don't tell me because I'm
going to read your mind.
I'm going to tell you.
This is not good.
They're arguing
over the last card.
I'll have to read
one of your minds.
What's that?
The 11 of clubs.
That's hard one to predict.
Make your best guess
and write it down.
Don't tell me.
Write it down.
You got two?
Well, write them both.
I'll predict one of them.
I've never had a
dispute on what the--
because if you started
with the same position,
you've got to wind up
in the same position.
You wrote it down?
Now think about your
number really hard.
We'll take yours.
I'll trust you there.
Think about it
really hard because I
need the brain waves to come
over and read the mind here.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm getting a really strong
signal on the last card.
Maybe I don't know.
Maybe it's something--
it's really powerful.
I'm going to say it's
the queen of hearts.
Is that right?
Both were the queen of-- oh,
you were trying to screw me up,
mess with me.
So you both got the
queen of hearts.
Oh, you did.
So how many people got
the queen of hearts?
Oh wow.
How many people did not
get the queen of hearts.
Somebody.
OK.
Now there's a chance
you did it legitimately.
But usually, with
a deck, we're all
going to get the same last card.
Now in this case, it happened
to be the very last card.
That is typically not the case.
So very good.
So I read your mind.
So you guys get the
gift certificates here.
Very good.
One for you and
your sponsor there.
So it's clear how I read
his mind because I got
the same number everybody did.
And somehow it doesn't
matter where we started.
We all had the same
card at the end.
How is that possible?
There's nine different
starting points.
Why don't we wind up in
nine different places?
And why isn't there
a one in nine chance
that I guess his card?
Why do we all wind
up in the same place?
Any thoughts?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Get the same card.
After that you stay [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
If ever we had the
same card, then we're
going to track forever and
finish in the same card.
But why should we ever
get the same card?
What are the chances of that,
that we land on the same card?
Why don't we just keep
missing each other?
It's a 1 in 9
chance or something.
I don't know.
Why don't we keep missing?
AUDIENCE: It seems like
there are enough low cards
that you just move slowly
along and, eventually, you're
going to intersect.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I did make a lot
of 1's in the deck.
If I would've made
all these face
cards be 10's, the chances of
my reading your mind go down.
Why do they go down?
What does it have to do?
Why did I put a lot
of 1's in the deck?
AUDIENCE: It goes on longer.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: The game
goes on longer?
PROFESSOR: The game
goes on longer.
So there's more chances
to hit together.
Because at any given time--
you've got your card.
I've got mine.
If mine is behind you, I
got a chance to land on you.
And if you're behind
me in the deck,
you've got a chance to land
on me with your number.
And if the numbers
are smaller, there's
more chances to
land on each other.
And it is true that
on any given chance,
the chances are low that
we land on the same card.
But there's a lot of chances.
And if there's a
lot more chances
than the probability of
landing on each other,
we've got Murphy's law.
If you've got a lot of chances
and they're not less likely
than the number of chances
or the inverse of that,
then we expect to have
a certain bunch of times
that we're going to
land on each other.
And therefore, a very
high probability we do.
Now that was a little hand-wavy.
And in fact, there's a
reason it was hand-wavy.
Why doesn't Murphy's law
really apply in this case,
really mathematically apply?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They're not
mutually independent.
Once you draw one card,
it's not coming back.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
And it means that the knowledge
that we haven't collided yet
tells me something about the
cards we've seen-- not a lot,
but something maybe.
And it's a finite
deck which tells me
something about the
cards that are coming.
And it might influence
the probability
that we land together,
the next person
who's jumping on the deck.
And so the events of-- like
for example, in this case,
we let A i be the event of a
collision on the i-th jump.
And there's about 20 jumps in
this game, 10 for each of us
expected.
So A i is the event that we
collide on the i-th jump.
These events are not necessarily
mutually independent.
Now if I had an
infinite deck or a deck
with replacement so every card
is equally likely to come next
no matter what's
come in the past,
now you can start getting
some mutual independence here.
And then you could start
really applying the theorem.
Now in this case, you don't
expect 10 things to happen.
You expect a few.
But that's good enough
that, in fact-- so
we did a computer
simulation once
and I got about a 90%
chance that we'll all
be on the same card.
So I have a pretty good chance
that I'm going to guess right.
And so far, I haven't
guessed wrong.
But it will happen
some day that we'll
start with a different
first number,
and we will miss at
the end because they'll
be two possible outcomes.
Just the way it works
out with 52 cards.
Now of course, if
we have more cards
or I made more things be
1's instead of 9's, say,
my odds go up because the
number of events I've got,
the number of chances
to collide, increases.
And the chance of hitting
when I jump also increases.
Any questions on that game?
So the point of all this is
that if the expected number
of events to occur
is small, then
it's an upper bound
on the probability
that something happens, whether
they're independent or not.
If the expected number of events
to occur is bigger than 1,
large, and if the events
are mutually independent,
then you can be sure
one of those events
is going to occur-- very, very
likely one of them will occur.
And that's Murphy's law.
Any questions about
numbers of events to occur?
We'll talk more about the
probability in the numbers
of events that occur next time.
Before we do that,
I want to talk
about some more useful
facts about expectation.
Now we know from
linearity of expectation
that the expected value of
a sum of random variables
is the sum of the expected
values of the random variables.
Now we're going to look at the
expected value of a product
of random variables.
And it turns out there's
a very nice rule for that.
Theorem 4, and it's the
product rule for expectation.
And it says that for-- if
your random variables are
independent, R1 and
R2 are independent,
then the expected value
of their product, also
a random variable, is simply the
product of the expected values.
So it's sort of the
equivalent thing
to linearity of expectation,
except we're doing products.
And you need independence.
Now the proof of this is not
too hard, and it's in the book.
So we're not going
to do it in class.
But we can give an example.
Say we roll two six-sided
fair and independent dice.
And I want to know what's the
expected product of the dice.
So we're going to let R1 be
the value on the first die,
and R2 would be the
value on the second one.
And the expected
value of the product
is the product of
the expectations.
And we already know the expected
value of a single die is 7/2.
So we get 7/2 times 7/2
is 49/4 or 12 and 1/4.
So it's easy to compute the
expected product of two dice.
Any questions about that?
Much easier than looking at all
36 outcomes to use this rule.
Now what if the dice we're
rigged, glued together somehow
so they always came up the same?
Would the expected
product B 12 and 1/4 then?
No?
Why not?
Why wouldn't it be the case?
Why isn't the
expected value of R1
squared the square of
the expected value of R1?
Isn't that what this says?
AUDIENCE: Independent.
PROFESSOR: They're
not independent.
R1 is not independent of R1
In fact, it's the same thing.
And you need independence
for that to be the case.
So a non example, the
expected value of R1 times R1
is the expected
value of R1 squared.
And to do that, we got
to go back to the basics.
We're taking the six
possible values of R1.
i equals 1 to 6.
i squared, because
we're squaring it,
times the probability
R1 equals i.
And each of those
probabilities is 1/6.
So we get 1/6 times 1 plus 4
plus 9 plus 16 plus 25 plus 36.
And if you add all that
up you get 15 and 1/6,
which is not 3 and 1/2
squared, which is the expected
value of R1 squared.
So the expected
value of the square
is not necessarily the
square of the expectation.
Because a random variable
is not independent of itself
generally.
OK.
Any questions there?
There's a couple of
quick corollaries.
The first is you take
this rule and apply it
to many random variables as long
as they're mutually dependent.
So if R1 R2 out to R n
are mutually independent,
then the expected
value of their product
is the product of
the expected values.
And the proof is just by
induction on the number
of random variables.
So that's pretty easy.
There's another easy corollary.
And that says, for any
constants, constant values,
a and b, and any
random variable R,
the expected value of a times
R plus b is simply a times
the expected value of R plus b.
And the reason that's
true-- well, the sum
works because of linearity
of expectation for the sum.
You can think of b as a random
variable that just always
has the value b.
And the a comes out
in front because you
can think of it as a
random variable that
always has a value a.
And that's independent of
any other random variable
because it never changes.
So by the product rule,
the a can come out.
Now you've got to
prove all that.
But it's not too hard and
not especially interesting.
So we won't do that here.
Any questions about those?
So we've got a
rule for computing
the sum of random variables,
a rule for the product
of random variables.
What about a rule for the
ratio of random variables?
Let's look at that.
So is this the corollary?
In fact, let's take the
inverse of random variable.
Is the expected value
of 1/R equal to 1
over the expected value of
R for any random variable R?
Some folks saying yes.
Some saying no.
What do you think?
Is that true?
Oh, got a mix.
How many say yes?
How many say no?
Oh, more no's.
Somebody tell me
why that's not true.
Who would like to
give me an example?
Give us an example there
that'll be very convincing.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I don't think it's
one that would be immediately
obvious, but I think if R is
the result of the roll of a die,
I don't think it works out.
PROFESSOR: So it's 50
chance of-- oh, I see.
So I take the average of 1/i--
that's sort of hard to compute.
I got to do [INAUDIBLE]
the sixth harmonic number
and then invert it.
There's an easier way to
show that this is false.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The expected
value equals 0?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The expected value
equals 0 which
could happen if R is plus 1
or minus 1 equally likely.
So here's an example here.
So R equals 1 with
probability 1/2, and minus 1
with probability 1/2.
So the expected value of R is 0.
So that blows up.
That's infinity.
What's the expected
value of 1/R?
Well, 1/1 and 1 over
minus 1, it's the same.
It equals 0.
And this would say 0 equals 1/0.
That's not true.
So this is false.
It is not true for
every random variable.
So once you see this example,
just obviously not true.
In fact, there's very
few random variables
for which this is true, even
an indicator random variable.
So it's 1 with probability 1/2
and 0 with probability 1/2.
Then the expected value
of 1/R is infinite.
1 over the expected
value of R is 2.
So it's clearly not true.
Let's do another one.
What about this
potential corollary?
Given independent random
variables R and T,
if the expected value
or R/T is bigger than 1,
then the expected value of R
is bigger than the expected
value of T. And let me even give
you a potential proof of this,
see if you like this proof.
Well, let's assume the expected
value of R/T is bigger than 1.
And let's multiply both sides
by the expected value of T.
And well, the product rule
says that this is just
the expected value
of R/T times T, which
is just the expected value
of R because the T's cancel.
So I gave you a proof.
Anybody have any
quibbles with this proof?
Yeah?
That's a big problem.
R/T is not independent
of T. [INAUDIBLE]
if T is very big, likely
that R/T is small.
So we can't do that step.
We can't use the independence
here to go from here to here.
That's wrong.
There's actually another
big problem with this proof.
Anybody see another problem?
Yeah?
Yeah.
If the expected value
of T is negative,
I would end up doing that.
So that step's wrong.
So this is a pretty lousy proof.
Every step is wrong.
So this is not a
good one to use.
And in fact, the
theorem is wrong.
Not only is the proof wrong,
but the result is wrong.
It's not true.
And we can see examples.
We'll do some
examples in a minute.
Now the amazing thing is that
despite the fact that this
is just blatantly wrong,
it is used all the time
in research papers.
And let me give you
a famous example.
This is a case of, actually, a
pretty well-known paper written
by some very famous computer
science professors at Berkeley.
And let me show
you what they did.
And this is so that
you will never do this.
They were trying to compare
two instruction sets way back
in the day.
And they were comparing
the RISC architecture
to something called the Z8002.
And they were
proponents of RISC.
And they were using this to
prove that it was a better way
to do things.
So they had a bunch of benchmark
problems, probably 20 or so
in the paper.
And I'm not going
to do all 20 here.
I'm going to give you a flavor
for what the data showed.
And then they looked at
the code size for RISC
and the other guys, Z8002.
And then they took the ratio.
So the first problem was
called E-string search,
whatever that is.
But it was some benchmark
problem out there at the time.
And the code length
on RISC was 150
say-- I've changed these
numbers a little bit
to make them simpler.
Code length here and
the Z8002 is 120.
The ratio is 0.8.
So for this problem, you're
trying to get low, short code.
So this was a better way
to go to support that.
And they had something
called F-bit test.
And here you have 120 lines.
Here's 180.
So in this case, risk is better.
So the ratio of that way
to this way would be 1.5.
And they had computing
and Ackermann function.
And that was 150 and 300.
So a big win for
RISC, ratio of 2.
And then they had a thing called
recursive sorting problem.
This is a hard problem.
There's 2,800 lines on RISC.
1400 on the old way.
Ratio of 0.5.
And there was a bunch more which
I'm not going to go through.
But their analysis, what they
did is they took the ratio,
and then they averaged it.
And so when you do this, you get
an average of, well, 2.3, 4.3,
4.8/4 is 1.2.
So the conclusion is that on
average code in this framework
is 20% longer than
the code on RISC.
Therefore, clearly, RISC
is a better way to go.
Your code on average
will be shorter.
Using the Z8002 on average,
the code will be 20% longer.
Makes perfect sense, right?
In fact, this is one of
the most common things
that is done when people
are comparing two systems.
Now just one problem with
this approach, and that's
that it's completely
bogus, completely bogus.
You cannot conclude--
let's make this conclusion.
So their conclusion, they
concluded that Z8002 programs
are 20% longer on average.
Everybody understands
the reasoning why, right?
Take the ratio of all the
test cases, average them up.
Then you get the average ratio.
Now there could be some
hint why this is bogus.
If I just looked at--
I took and summed
these numbers, if I add all
those numbers up, I get 3,220.
And all these, I get 2,000.
RISC code is not looking
shorter if I do that.
Looking longer.
But all that gain, all the loss
of RISC is in this one problem.
And maybe it's not
fair to do that.
And that's why when people
have data like this,
they just take the ratios.
Because now it would be-- if
I just took the average code
length and took
the ratio of that,
it's not fair because
one problem just
wiped out the whole thing.
I might as well not even do it.
And they want every
problem to count equally.
And that's why they
take the ratio,
to make them all count equally.
Let's do one more thing here.
Let's look at what happens
if we take the ratio of RISC
to the Z8002.
Make some room for that.
So this is-- this column
is Z8002 over RISC.
What if I just did this--
RISC over the Z8002 I mean
the answer should come
out to 1/1.2, right?
That's what we expect,
because I've just
been turning it upside down.
Well, I get 1.25 here.
These are just being inverted.
Here I've got 2/3, 0.67.
Here I get 1/2.
Here I get 2.
Let's add those up.
I get 1.92, 2.42, 4.42.
Divide by 4-- wow,
I get 1.1 something
which says, well, that
on average, RISC is
10% longer than the other one.
So same analysis says
that RISC programs
are 10% longer on average.
Now the beauty of
this method is you
can make any conclusion you
want seem reasonable, typically.
You could have the
exact same data.
And if you want RISC to look
better you do it this way.
If you want RISC to look
worse, you do it that way.
You see?
Is that possible?
Is it possible for
one to be 20% longer
than the other on average,
but the other be 10% longer
on average?
How many people think
that's possible?
We had some weird things
happen in this class,
but that's not possible.
That can't happen.
These conclusions
are both bogus.
Now I'm not teaching you
this so that later when
you're doing your PhD thesis
and it's down to the wire
and you need a conclusion
to be proved, good news.
You can prove it.
No matter what your conclusion
is, you can prove it.
That's not why we're doing this.
We're doing this so you can spot
the flaw in this whole setup
and that you'll never do this.
And you'll see it when other
people do because people do it
all the time.
So let's try to put some
formality under this
in terms of probability.
Because when you start
talking about averages,
really think about expectations
of random variables and stuff.
So let's try to view this
as a probability problem
and see if we can shed
some light on what's
going on here because it
sure seemed reasonable.
So let's let x be the benchmark.
And maybe that'll be
something in the sample space,
an outcome in the sample space.
Let's let R x be the code
length for RISC on x and Z x
be the code length for
the other processor on x.
And then we'll define a
probability of seeing x.
That's our problem
we're looking at.
And typically, you might
assume that it's uniform,
the distribution there.
We need this to be able to
define an expected value
for R and for Z.
Now what they're doing in the
paper, what really is happening
here, is instead of this, they
have the expected value of Z/R
is 1.2.
That is what they can conclude.
That does not mean that
the expected value of Z
is 1.2, the expected
value of R, which
is what they conclude
that the Z8002 code is
20% longer than RISC code.
This is true.
That is not implied.
And why not?
That's just, actually, what
this corollary was doing.
Really, it's just
what we were-- they
made the same false assumption
as happened in the corollary.
You can't multiply both sides
here by the expected value of R
and then get the expected value
Z. Of course, if you ask them,
they would have known that.
But they don't
even think through
that, they just used the
standard method of taking
the expected value of a ratio.
So this is fair to conclude.
But as we saw, the expected
value of R/Z was 1.1.
So both of these can be
true at the same time.
That's fine.
But you can't make
the conclusions
that they tried to make.
Here's another-- in
fact, in this case,
if we had a uniform
distribution,
the expected value of R
is like 805 for uniform.
And the expected
value of Z is 500.
And that's all you
can conclude if you're
taking uniform distribution.
In which case, of course,
if they're promoting RISC,
well, you don't like
that conclusion.
So it's better to
get this one's.
I don't think it was
intentional of course.
But it's nice that
it came out that way.
Here's another example that
really makes it painfully clear
why you never want to do this.
So a really simple case, just
generic variables R and Z.
And I got two problems only--
problem one, problem two.
R is 2 for problem
1, and z is 1.
And they reverse on problem 2.
Z/R is 2 and 1/2.
R/Z, just the reverse.
Now the expected
value of R/Z here
is 2 plus 1/2 divided
by 2 is 1 and 1/4.
And what's the
expected value of Z/R?
The average of
these is 1 and 1/4,
what's the average of these?
Same thing, 1 and 1/4.
So never, ever take
averages of ratios
without really knowing
what you're doing.
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What would be the
word explanation of the expected
value of Z/R?
What is that?
PROFESSOR: That is the
average of the ratio.
It is not the ratio
of the average.
They are very different things.
And you can see how you
get caught up in that.
You could see how you have
linearity of expectation,
you got the product
rule for expectation.
You do not have a rule that
says this implies that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Which two?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Z/R?
PROFESSOR: Well, in
this case, they're one.
I don't think that'll
be true in general.
AUDIENCE: Does that
give you information?
PROFESSOR: They give
you information.
That may not be the
information you want.
It wouldn't imply
that which is what
you're after in some sense.
But it gives you
some information.
It's the expected average ratio.
The problem is the human brain
goes right from there to here.
It's just you do.
It's hard to help
yourself from doing it.
And it's not true.
That's the problem.
We have a version of this in the
one in the homework questions
which is true.
But it's a special
version of it where
you can say something positive.
Any questions about this?
So anybody ever shows
you an average of ratios,
you want the light to go
off and say, danger, danger.
Think what's happening here.
Or if you're ever analyzing
data to compare two systems.
So we talked a lot
about expectation, seen
a lot of ways of computing it.
We've done a lot of examples.
For the rest of today
and for next time,
we're going to talk
about deviations
from the expected value.
Now for some random
variables, they
are very likely to
take on values that
are near their expectation.
For example, if
I flip 100 coins.
And say they're fair and
mutually independent.
We know that the expected
number of heads is 50.
Does anybody remember
the probability
of getting far from that, namely
having 25 or fewer heads or 75
or more heads?
Remember, we did that?
It was a couple of weeks ago?
Is it likely to have
25 or fewer heads?
AUDIENCE: It's less
than 1 in a million?
PROFESSOR: Less
than 1 in a million.
Yeah.
It was 1 in 5
million or something.
I don't know, some
horribly small number.
So if I flip 100 coins,
I expect to get 50 heads.
And I'm very likely to
get close to 50 heads.
I'm not going to be 25 off.
And then the example
we had in recitation,
you got a noisy
channel, and you expect
an error rate, 1% of your
10,000 bits to be corrupted.
The chance of
getting 2% corrupted
was like-- what was it, 2 to
the minus 60 or something?
Extremely unlikely to be
far from the expected value.
But there's other cases where
you are likely-- you could well
be far from the expected value.
Can anybody remember
an example we've
done where you are almost
surely way off your expected
value for a random variable?
Anybody remember an example
we did that has that feature?
AUDIENCE: The appetizer I think.
PROFESSOR: The appetizer.
Let's see.
Appetizers, you expect 1, but
you're almost certain to be 0.
Or actually, you're
almost certain to be 0,
and you have a
chance of being n.
So if you count 0
as being close to 1,
you're likely to be close
to your expectation.
Because you're likely to
be 0, and you expect 1.
Remember that noisy
channel problem--
not the noisy channel,
the latency problem
across the channel?
And we show that the expected
latency was infinite?
But 99% of the time you
had 10 milliseconds,
something like that?
There's an example where
almost all the time you
are far from your expectation
which is infinite.
So there are examples
that go both ways.
Now let's look at another
couple of examples
that'll motivate the
definition that measures this.
I'd say that we've got a simple
Bernoulli random variable where
the probability that
R is 1,000 is 1/2,
and the probability that
R is minus 1,000 is 1/2.
Then the expected
value of R is 0.
Similarly, we could
have another one, S,
where the probability
that S equals 1 is 1/2,
and the probability that
S equals minus 1 is 1/2.
And the expected
value of S is 0.
Now if this was a
betting game and we're
talking about dollars--
here's where you're
wagering $1,000, fair game.
Here's where you're wagering $1.
Now in this game--
both games are fair.
Expected value is 0.
But here you're likely to end
up near your expected value.
Here you're certain to be far by
some measure from your expected
value.
And in fact, if you were
offered to play a game,
you might have a real decision
as to which game you played.
If you like risk, you
might play that game.
If you're risk averse, maybe
you stick with this game
because what you could
lose would be less.
Now this motivates the
definition of the variance
because it helps mathematicians
distinguish between these two
cases with a simple statistic.
The variance of a
random variable R--
we'll denote it by
var, V-A-R, of R--
is defined as the expected
value of the random variable
minus this expected
value squared.
That's sort of a mouthful there.
So let's break it down.
This is the expected value
of R. This is the deviation
from the expected value.
So this is the
deviation from the mean.
Then we square it.
So that equals the
square of the deviation.
And then we take the
expected value of the square.
So the variance equals
the expected value
of the square of the deviation.
In other words, the
variance gives us
the average of the
squares of the amount
by which the random variable
deviates from its mean.
Now the idea behind this is
that if a random variable is
likely to deviate from its
mean, the variance will be high.
And if it's likely
to be near its mean,
the variance will be low.
And so variance can tell us
something about the expected
deviation.
So let's compute the
variance for R and S
and see what happens.
So with R minus the
expected value of R, well,
that is going to be
1,000, because you expect
the value of 0, with
probability 1/2, and minus 1,000
with probability 1/2.
Then I square that.
Well, I square 1,000, I get a
million with probability 1/2.
And I square minus
1,000, I get a million
again with probability 1/2.
And so therefore,
the variance of R,
well, it's the expected value
of this, which is-- well,
it's always a million.
So it's just a million.
Big.
Now if I were to do this with S,
S minus the expected value of S
is 1 with probability 1/2,
minus 1 with probability 1/2.
If I square that, well,
I get 1 squared is 1,
minus 1 squared is 1.
And so the variance of S is
the expected value of this.
And that's just 1.
So a big difference
in the variance.
So the variance being different
tells us these random variables
are-- the distributions
are very different even
though their expected
values are the same.
And the guy with
big variance says,
hey, we're likely to
deviate from the mean here.
And so risk averse people
stay away from strategies
when they're investing
that have high variance.
Now does anybody have any idea
why we square the deviation?
Why don't we just-- why
didn't mathematicians
when they figured out
this stuff I don't know
how many centuries ago,
why didn't they just take
the expected deviation?
Why do the stupid
squaring thing?
That only is going
to complicate it?
Why don't we instead
compute the expected value
of R minus the mean?
Why didn't they do that
and call that the variance?
Yeah?
That's zero.
Yeah.
Because by linearity
of expectation,
that corollary
[? 4-2 ?] or whatever,
this is just the expected value
of R minus the expected value
of the expected value of R. The
expected value of a scalar is
just that scalar.
And that is 0.
So the expected
deviation from the mean
is 0 because of how
the mean is defined.
It's the midpoint,
the weighted midpoint.
The times you're high
cancel out the times you're
low if you got the mean right.
And so this is a
useless definition.
It's always 0.
So mathematicians had to do
something to capture this.
Now what would have been
the more logical thing
to do that is the next step.
This doesn't work,
but what would
you think the mathematicians
would've done?
Absolute value would have
made a lot of sense here.
Why they didn't do that?
Well, you could
do that, but it's
hard to work with
mathematically.
You can't prove nice
theorems, it turns out.
If you put the square in there
and make that be the variance,
you can prove a theorem
about linearity of variance.
And if the random
variables are independent,
then the variance of the sum
is the sum of the variances.
And mathematicians like
that kind of thing.
It makes it easier to work
with and do things with.
Now there are also other
choices like, in fact,
there's a special name
for a weird case where
you take the fourth power.
You could do that.
As long as an even
power, you could do it.
And that's actually
called the kurtosis.
Sounds like a foot disease.
But it's the kurtosis
of the random variable.
Now we're not going to worry
about that in this class.
But we are going to
worry about variance.
And let me do one
more definition,
then we'll talk about
variance a lot more tomorrow.
That square is a bit of a pain.
And to get rid of it, they
made another definition
after the fact called
the standard deviation.
And standard deviation
is defined as follows.
For a random variable R,
the standard deviation of R
is denoted by a sigma
of R. And it's just
the square root of
the variance, undoing
that nasty square
root after the fact.
So it turns out to be the
square root of the expectation
of the deviation squared.
Another name for this
you've probably seen,
it's the root of the mean of
the square of the deviations.
And so you get this thing
called root-mean-square,
which if any of
you ever done curve
fitting or any of
those kinds of things
in statistics or whatever, this
is what you're talking about.
And so that's why that
expression were to come about.
So for the standard
deviation of R--
what's the standard
deviation of R?
1,000?
In effect, that's
pretty close to what
you expect the deviation to be.
What's the standard
deviation of S?
1.
Square root of 1
is 1, and that's
what you expect its
deviation to be.
So we'll do more of this
tomorrow on recitation.